la semaine dernière le ministre de la
santé du québec le dr gaétan barrette a
affirmé que le système de santé pourrait
épargner des coûts substantielles si on
sait c'est la pratique de l'examen
médical annuel qui selon lui n'a plus sa
raison d'être
une affirmation qui a fait sursauter
beaucoup de citoyens puisque cette
pratique est encore très répandue et
qu'elle est jugée nécessaire parce
qu'ils ont à coeur leur santé michel
bonsoir bonsoir il dit qu'au fond
l'examen médical annuel c'est pas très
utile sur le poids du point de vue
médical scientifique est ce qu'il dit
vrai bon il ya eu beaucoup d'études de
céline à ce sujet là et le docteur
barrette dit vrai maintenant il faut
voir ce que ces études là disent
exactement
alors regardons ça si vous êtes
quelqu'un entre l'âge de 18 et 65 ans et
que vous êtes en santé ça c'est très
important
cet examen médical annuel ne change pas
le taux de mortalité au bout de la ligne
par rapport à ceux qui n'en n'ont pas
d'examen annuel c'est utile par contre
pour les personnes qui ont des maladies
chroniques qui ont des symptômes
persistants ou des prédispositions
héréditaire à des maladies pour ces gens
là ont suivi nécessaire alors comment
est-ce qu'on en arrive à ces conclusions
là bon alors je vais vous présenter une
grande étude qui était fait en 2012 une
méta analyse faite par un groupe qui
s'appelle la collaboration cockerill qui
remontent également reconnu alors ce que
ces gens là ont fait là bas c'est de
définir ce que c'est que cet examen est
là parce que beaucoup de gens savent pas
exactement ce que c'est c'est quand un
médecin fait de la prospective
il veut analyser de votre personne qui
serait les maladies possibles pour
l'ensemble des organes qui regardent
votre style de vie votre alimentation
fait passer des tests sanguins souvent
ou une radiographie
donc c'est un bilan complet car il a
regardé 16 études peu près de deux cent
mille personnes des gens qui en ont eu
des gens qui n'ont pas eu sur une longue
période plus de dix ans et voilà les
conclusions
alors si vous suivez un examen médical
annuel ça ne réduira pas votre mortalité
votre morbidité pour l'ensemble de la
population des maladies
cardiovasculaires du cancer ou de
n'importe quelle autre maladie s'amène
seul ont cru dans un surdiagnostic et un
surtraitement et quand il conclu
dix ans que pour l'ensemble d'une
société ce n'est pas nécessairement
bénéfique et là on parle pas bien sûr
par exemple du path est pour les femmes
par exemple on voit là effectivement si
vous voulez suite des tests de dépistage
pour un cancer prostate les ovaires le
sein à l'isi ça ne constitue pas en soi
un examen médical annuel
alors commence à tirer qui soit si
populaire ces examens que les gens
vraiment l'impression que ça les aide à
se garder en santé
ben voilà dans la dans la pratique ça
commence à être contestée de plus en
plus parce que ça mais nous sur ce
diagnostic au surtraitement la
population croit à tort que c'est la
prévention la vraie prévention sedin ça
commence par surveiller son alimentation
faire de l'exercice bien dormir à garder
ses antécédents familiaux et contient
votre c'est une bonne chose
alors si vous êtes en santé je crois que
ce n'est pas nécessaire rapidement
quelques exceptions quand même oui si
vous souffrez de maladies chroniques les
prenait beaucoup de médicaments
il faut pour des raisons médicales
suivre un examen annuel pour voir
comment tout ça évolue dans le temps
c'est essentiel voilà c'est très clair
merci beaucoup de chaises mais aussi
céline